[Music]
thank you
now let's turn our attention to America
where this week the house Speaker the
Republican house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
has announced that Congress will be
launching an impeachment inquiry into
Joe Biden over his links or possible
cooperation with
Hunter Biden his son's dodgy business
dealings with foreign entities it's a
very murky topic and the Republicans
have been digging at it for some time
however pushing on towards an
impeachment is a significant move and
could change the story entirely
I'm joined Now by Alan dershowitz who is
the lawyer as well as the author of get
Trump
and Alan I thought about I'd say start
by asking you
um there's quite a few commentators who
are already saying that this is a big
mistake from the Republicans at least
from a political point of view do you
agree with them
I think so I think they're making the
same mistake the Democrats made when
they tried to impeach president Trump
twice on grounds that were not
acceptable on the Constitution there's
no basis in the Constitution for
impeaching a president who has quote
created a culture of corruption which is
what McCarthy said about him he has to
have committed treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanors I don't
even think he has enough Republicans at
this point to bring about a vote in the
house he's just setting out the members
of the committee to investigate it's
designed largely for internal political
purposes Congressman uh uh from Florida
and other places have threatened the
leadership of McCarthy unless he moves
against the Biden so this is a political
decision it will backfire in the same
way I think that the Republicans uh have
made it backfire against the Democrats
uh when Trump was impeached I predicted
this when I defended president Trump on
the floor of the Senate I predict that
the Republicans would do the same thing
tit protat and it's wrong when either
side does it neither side should be
allowed to weaponize and distort the
Constitution well I think we should talk
about that next but it struck me that
the timing is quite bad for the
Republicans in that Joe Biden has just
been uh on a international trip he went
to Hanoi and delivered a very
embarrassing speech where he didn't seem
to know where he was uh there was a CNN
poll out last week that showed him
performing very very badly
um with the American public I think 75
percent
of Americans are seriously concerned
about his mental and physical health
um what the Republicans seem to have
done though now is perhaps changed the
narrative and flipped the script at
precisely the time
um when the Electoral calculus seemed to
be settling in their favor both sides
are doing that both sides of scrambling
the Electoral calculus the Democrats are
trying to indict president uh former
president Trump to try to remove him
under the 14th amendment that too
distorts the Constitution both sides are
trying to use the Constitution to
improve their electoral chances and I
think in both cases they may actually uh
backfire I think what you were getting
at earlier Alan is uh this idea of
impeach inflation
uh that was meant to be a emergency
mechanism
um in the U.S Constitution is now being
cheapened uh since we've had this is now
uh the third
um impeachment inquiry in four years
um and that it's ties into exactly what
worries Americans most about their
politics which is that um it's
completely dysfunctional
um and it's just two sides using legal
mechanisms and all sorts of dirty tricks
against each other
um and that the political system is
broken uh is that not the real problem
here
yes in fact James Madison the father of
the Constitution said that misusing
impeachment would turn the United States
into Great Britain uh because in Great
Britain it's very easy to get rid of the
Prime Minister just to vote of lack of
confidence uh as we have seen over the
years and the U.S presidency was
supposed to be stronger and more
enduring than the Prime ministership in
any parliamentary country and so Madison
rejected the concept of impeaching a
president for Mal Administration or for
doing the kinds of things that the uh
Republicans now claim that President
Trump uh uh President Biden has been
doing in that and the Democrats claim
that President Trump was doing
um Great Britain's a great country but
we have a different method of rooting
ourselves of the chief executive than
Great Britain does lastly and I don't
know if you've seen this slightly
eccentric story uh about the libertarian
party which is actually America's third
largest political party and they've
applied to put Joe Biden and uh Senate
minority leader Mitch McConnell
um who's 81 Biden is 80.
um under a conservatorship uh because
they feel that the elites are too
geriatric to be trusted with running
America
um it's obviously a bit of a stunt uh
but firstly with your legal hat on do
you think it's actually feasible
no no we we do have a geriatric C uh we
have too many old people and too many
high positions of uh Power
um we need more young people in politics
but the answer to that is not some kind
of a mechanism for uh for changing the
election system if you don't like who is
the leader Your Leader vote against them
uh I'm gonna vote against uh Donald
Trump for the third time many people
will vote against Biden uh for the
second time that's the method of removal
in the United States none of them have
committed impeachable or removable
offenses Alan dershowitz uh author of
get Trump
thank you very much for joining us thank
you
[Music]